[Music]
there are some really cool
collaborations on this record a step
Rock II said but I love you and Hall
sees voices together how did those come
about in a really organic way
I actually met all three of those
artists and then the collaborations
happened as a result of us getting to
know each other becoming friends and so
that's nice
and when you share a song with someone
at least for me it's a highly personal
experience and I've only ever had a
collaborator and what other song really
and my life besides my brother it was
Kanye West right and it was a great
experience he was phenomenal to work
with he said that he was a big
inspiration for you and that you loved
his bravery what do you mean by that
well I mean I think it's pretty obvious
he just doesn't give a [ __ ] and he does
what inspires him and I think that we
all need to remember that we as artists
that you have an opportunity to reach to
fail to take chances run away from the
baby
run away sure I went back and I listen
to sort of all of the classics and the
records and preparation for this and is
there ever gonna be a record where
everything's okay it's like are you ever
just gonna be like writing us a love
song look at me don't I look completely
at peace we are so then as a human if
you only could feel the river of anxiety
running through my veins
no there I think there are moments on
the album lived like a dream okay I
think great wide open has the kind of
stoic aspirational feel to it I think
walk and water is a song about
empowerment it's about freedom it's
about change
yeah it's Bob but it's it's it's an
album filled with the diverse group of
songs yeah motion Aletha Matic least I
was never just like an acoustic guitar
like when I look into your eyes you know
who does that really really well and I
just could never even do anything as
good as him is Ed Sheeran
[Music]
he writes songs about you know breakups
but also probably songs about falling in
love and you know when you do it that
well when there's someone around doing
it as well as that sure and why bother
right
why bother I'm gonna stay in my lane
which is filled with discontent and you
know darkness
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]